gentlemen
shall we
so i love me some succession i actually
think it's the best show on tv at the
moment and now it's almost back and i'm
gonna be recapping it every single week
so yeah drop a sub if you're interested
in talking all things succession but
before that i thought i'd make this
little preparation pack for us all so if
you haven't seen it or you've forgotten
what happened or even if you just love
succession and want more cousin greg
content this video will recap everything
that's happened so far goes without
saying but i can't do this vid without
spoilers guys so if you want to watch
the show go and watch it now i won't
even be mad it's such a great show that
you wholeheartedly have my permission to
leave and with that being said let's
jump in fight to describe succession in
one sentence i would say a rich and
powerful american family fight for
control over a media empire when the
patriarch refuses to give up his power i
think that's a pretty solid summary the
main family of the roys they own a media
conglomerate called waystar royco and
they are very closely modeled on
powerful real-life media families like
the murdochs those are the main dot
points but before diving into the main
plot i thought i'd start with a quick
summary of all the main players the head
honcho and founder of waystar royko is
logan roy coming from humble beginnings
in scotland logan's main focus is the
running of his company rather than the
lives of his four children a master
manipulator and veteran businessman he
doesn't mince his words and values power
above all else what are you waiting for
a kiss
[ __ ] off as such he is constantly
paranoid that somebody is coming for his
throne which brings us to the possible
heirs of his vast kingdom his four
children first we have kendall the
presumed successor at the beginning of
season one due to his high executive
position within the company
i think walter is the shiz
where there she is a recovering addict
kendall has straightened out and is
hell-bent on proving his worth to logan
the only way he knows how by making
business deals that better way star
roiko he's seemingly the most self-aware
of the roy's due to his constant fear of
relapsing and disappointing his dad
because of this i'd argue kendall is the
most interesting character as he is
constantly striving to become his father
but his personality changes so rapidly
throughout the show due to his crippling
fear of failure that he is stuck in a
perpetual identity crisis kendall has an
estranged wife rava and two children the
youngest son roman is the family's
jester partying sarcasm and immaturity
are his hallmarks and he hides behind a
rich quippy veneer when in reality he is
also desperate for his father's approval
what are you doing taking my shirt off
that's all
from everyone i've talked to roman seems
like the most polarizing character in
the show you either love him or hate him
i personally think he's hilarious the
start of season 1 he decides to be taken
more seriously and often finds himself
biting heads with kendall in their power
struggle he's a party boy so has no
family but spends a large chunk of the
series trying to find a live partner
because it's what he's supposed to do
this leads to a fling with tabitha and a
weird mother-son thing with jerry
logan's eldest son and the other
sibling's half-brother connor is a meme
he's happy living off the generational
wealth of his father and lives a
decadent lifestyle while preaching
minimalistic [ __ ] he's easily the
biggest supporter of logan amongst the
siblings but as he provides no worth to
the family is generally seen as an
afterthought it's sourdough started to
make bread
without yeast the old way oh
oh
okay
old bread
thank you whenever a family conflict
arises he takes the neutral stance and
stays out of it he's obsessed with an
escort named willa who he pays an
exorbitant amount of money to be his
girlfriend like i said he's a meme but
yeah he still has his moments shiv is
logan's only daughter and is seen as the
smartest of the four she works in the
political sphere as an advisor which
leads to conflicts of interest when her
clients butt heads with the ideologies
of waystar royco as an outsider who
doesn't work within the company logan
values shiv for her strategic guile and
objective decision making as such he
tempts her with the role of the top job
later in the show out of the four
children i'd say shiv is the most stable
well
to be fair conor is consistently an
idiot but of the three that have
reasonable aspirations shiv is the most
level-headed she makes decisions with
both her head and her heart and seems
less focused on power than kendall and
roman now this isn't to say she plays
fair she's more than capable of getting
her hands dirty to win but she often
seems to value the idea of winning more
than the power that comes with this
success shiv is romantically involved
with this man tom womsgans an employee
who is the head of parks and planning at
way star royco and an absolute goober
tom is one of the only main characters
who is not a roy but by god does he wish
he was tom represents the upper middle
class who have scrapped and fought their
way up the corporate ladder and whose
ultimate goal is to break through to the
elusive world of the global elite shiv
is his conduit into this world and as
such their relationship comes across as
a relationship of convenience more than
anything else shiv gets a stable
reliable partner and tom gets access to
the elusive club due to his lower social
status and quirky behaviour time is
often the part of the roy's jokes within
the show he has two definitive
personalities first is his more formal
personality when he is around the roys
he sucks up to logan and tries to avoid
offending anyone as much as possible
it's incredibly accurate every time you
look at it tells you exactly how rich
you are
that's very funny
did you rehearse that
no no well no yes
his second personality is the complete
opposite he asserts his authority and
exudes power by bullying and harassing
those lower than his stature he has a
three and a half time weight limit and
uh he's worried about his mirrors well
which is it charlotte the story keeps
changing this to me is what makes tom
such an intriguing character he spends
most of the show telling other
characters how to act rich but then once
put in these situations he acts a bit
like a dog who's caught the mailman and
doesn't know what to do next his default
response is bullying and abuse as he
seems to be trying to emulate how
kendall and roman treat him he thinks
this is what rich people are supposed to
do this paints him as a tragic figure
but i think he's the second funniest
character in the show which begs the
question who's the funniest that title
belongs to greg hirsch or cousin greg as
he is commonly referred to it's it's
greg
no yeah yeah
people
sometimes like mistakenly call me craig
too so i'll answer to both the grandson
of logan's brother greg is a blood
relative to the roys but otherwise a
complete stranger if tom represents the
upper middle class greg represents the
everyman he stumbles into the family
turmoil in the first episode and uses
his relative anonymity and cunning to
work his way into the inner circle
because of his affable personality and
lack of corporate experience the other
characters regularly underestimate
greg's intelligence and he often
switches his allegiances to progress his
own career even in the second episode
he's playing shiv and roman against one
another simply put he's a manipulative
sneaky boy old greg greg snakes his way
into a job at waist up royco but then
has to deal with the crazy tom for most
of his time at work what what am i doing
stop helping no i'm gonna stop you [ __ ]
unquestionably my favorite character i'm
very much hashtag team greg and if you
don't know much about the actor who
betrays him nicholas braun check him out
you won't regret it he's pretty much
cousin greg in real life oh yeah there's
also marsha logan's third wife she's an
ice queen and i hate her has a real
hate-hate relationship with all the kids
but they have to put up with her because
logan wants them to go out and see how
you like it
[ __ ]
it's clearly keen on claiming some of
the power herself and as logan's closest
advisor and confidant has a large say in
the company's operation so those are the
main characters but here's a quick fire
round of the recurring peripheral
characters before jumping into the plot
jerry the general counsel of the waystar
royco is a legitimate og close with
logan and knows the kids well frank ceo
of waystar royco another og has been
friends with logan for 30 years he's
regularly roasted by roman and gets
fired 43 times in the show karl waystar
roico's chief financial officer hates
making decisions carolina head of pr
away star royko gets shouted out 100
times a day and stops them getting sued
stewie an iranian-american financier who
is one of kendall's close friends in my
mind this is who tom wants to be
lawrence the founder of the media
company who waystar royco acquires
prickly customer nate one of shiv's old
flames gets her a job with this man gill
a democratic presidential candidate he
hates way star royko sandy owns a rival
media conglomerate and therefore is
logan's sworn enemy phew i think that's
all the main characters also everyone
let me know in the comments below who
your favorite character is you have no
excuses there are about 43 million of
them now onto the show itself
hi guys i'm just jumping in to say i'm
not going to be covering every single
thing from every single scene so please
don't roast me if i don't include your
favorite scene if you're going to roast
me for anything roast me for this
yeah little moustache i'm growing all
right on to season one the first episode
is pretty important because it
communicates a lot of the character
traits i've just described in fact the
main thread of this opening episode is
kendall trying his hardest to close a
deal with lawrence remember this dude he
ends up overpaying but this communicates
his desperation to impress logan in fact
it's not even desperation to impress
it's more like desperation not to
disappoint all of the children are
terrified of disappointing their dad
which establishes a clear power
structure in the family from the start
we also get a lot of scenes with the
roys flexing their wealth like this
chopper scene any scene at their
ridiculous penthouse apartments and this
cruel baseball game where roman
tantalizes a poor child with a million
dollar check
great because i will give you one
million dollars if you hit a home run
so yeah we get it the roys are richer
than god and wield a lot of power or as
kendall puts it for socioeconomic health
of multiple continents is dependent on
his well-being the family gets together
for logan's 80th birthday and at this
event he announces that he's not
stepping down as ceo he then hands out
papers to all three of his kids naming
marsha the ice queen as his successor
and they're all like what
kendall has a full-on meltdown as he was
already planning his transition roman
thinks it's hilarious for this very
reason and shiv questions marsha's
motives and loyalty to the company and
connor
i don't really know what connor's doing
he's probably looking for some new
condiment or something anyway this
culminates in them flying back from the
baseball game and while arguing about
the papers logan has a stroke oh yeah
and frank got fired too lol miserable
bastard so we've got a power struggle a
rich family and now the king who won't
concede his throne is in intensive care
nice start then the next few episodes
follow the fallout from logan's
announcement and his stroke the kids
fight over who will become logan's
successor while the rest of the company
execs freak out about the company's
stock price taking a huge hit kendall
believes he should be ceo in a huge
shock and shiv doesn't trust marsha but
also doesn't like kendall and connor and
roman think they should just sign the
papers because that was logan's final
wish this one seen as a microcosm of the
entire show the children squabble and
each one finds it difficult to justify
their claim to the throne more
importantly they find it difficult to
justify anything kendall's main argument
is i should be ceo because i thought i
was going to be ceo and once anyone
brings up a reasonable counter he
crumbles under the pressure logan
refusing to step down and then having a
stroke is the first time in their
perfectly manicured lives that something
hasn't gone exactly to plan and this is
the beauty of the show succession builds
its tension around the siblings having
to improvise in the face of adversity
and you know what makes a character
interesting things going wrong showing
us the characters faults lets them grow
and evolve throughout the series and the
vulnerability of these elite powerful
people means us mere mortals can connect
with them so yeah i think that the
scriptwriting and characterization in
this show is absolutely elite anyway
what else happens in these epps tom
proposes to shiv greg runs some errands
for the family and jerry tells kendall
that way star royco is three billion
dollars in debt wait what oh yeah by
this stage the children agree that while
dad is ill the family proposes that
kendall run the company with roman as
ceo and as his first piece of business
kendall now has to deal with a three
billion dollar hole logan left them in
he calls his buddy stewie for some help
and luckily stu has a cheeky four
billion dollars hanging around so agrees
to stake them in exchange for a board
seat however greg later spots stewie
talking to sandy logan's sworn enemy so
clearly there's something fishy going on
there however the most interesting
relationship within these first few
episodes and i'd argue the entire show
is kendall and logan logan wakes up and
kendall goes to tell him the good news
he saved the company from crippling debt
and all it cost them was a board seat
for stewie however logan berates kendall
for making the deal this communicates
two important things to us number one
nothing kendall ever does will truly
impress his father the pure simplicity
of the unreciprocated father-son
relationship is devastating and drives
kendall's character development for the
next two seasons every decision kendall
makes over the next 18 episodes can be
traced back to this very moment number
two logan is petrified of being
dethroned and so will do anything in his
power to weaken challenges he is furious
at giving away a board seat as that
seeds some of his control but he also
sees kendall as a challenger so crushes
his mental resolve are you gonna [ __ ]
cry
i know this is a bad analogy but it's
like emperor palpatine in the star wars
movies i bet you weren't expecting any
star wars in the succession video hey
gotcha anyway velveteen's only goal is
obtaining unlimited power he knows in
order to maintain his level of control
over the galaxy he needs powerful
subordinates he can trust this is why he
takes on count dooku and darth vader as
his apprentices however his greatest
fear is losing that power therefore
whenever one of them starts becoming too
powerful or independent he manipulates
another apprentice to try and kill them
logan has the same fascination with
power it is both his biggest strength
and his biggest weakness therefore much
of succession's plot is based on logan
manipulating other powerful people
including his children in order to
maintain his position i don't know about
you guys but i'm not hanging out with
many fortune 500 ceos so i can't speak
to the accuracy of this depiction but
seems pretty accurate right once you
have generational wealth and power what
is the motivating factor for all your
decisions fear
the only direction from the top of the
mountaintop is down so you have to do
everything in your power to stay at the
peak anyway i think it's pretty
fascinating but that's enough waffle
from me back to the story there's a
weird subplot with shiv and marsha
fighting because the ice queen won't let
shiv see logan and seems to enjoy
asserting her position of power this
cold war continues for most of the show
which highlights the importance of
relationships and allegiances in tipping
the balance of power speaking of because
of tom and shiv's engagement tom gets a
little nepotism boost and is given a
promotion to become the head of
waystar's parks and cruises division
this should be a good thing but instead
he learns that the division has been
covering up some serious crimes aboard
the cruisers murders sexual assault it's
a potential pr disaster and tom is now
responsible for hiding it there's the
death pit and at the bottom of the death
pit there's nuclear rods
you want to give me the good news now
bill of course because he's an idiot he
panics and tells greg making greg an
accessory to the crimes
i mean i feel like i might not like it
in the death pit this leads to another
important threat in the first season the
emergence of cousin greg master
manipulator i mentioned this in the
character intros people continually
underestimate greg he's treated like a
clueless outsider and yes in high
society he certainly is clueless doesn't
even have money for food for most of the
first season and is regularly stealing
everything from the office kitchen
however he navigates his new world with
the guile of an all-star survivor
contestant to the point that he actually
has a huge impact on the story as
somebody who is seen by other characters
as a pawn they can use he collects a lot
of useful information from them which he
then uses to blackmail and manipulate
others during the cruise scandal greg
makes a few key decisions first he tells
jerry that tom wants to go public with
the news this shows him forming
connections with the top dogs in the
company earning favor for the future
secondly he makes copies of the
documents when tom tells him to shred
the evidence he later uses these
documents to blackmail kendall into a
better office and better position you
little machiavellian [ __ ]
i see you greg the most important
takeaway from this he is a roy after all
he's smart and aspirational and as such
he seems to be following in tom's
footsteps the difference he's just a bit
sneakier we'll get to this again in
season two but for now back to kendall
versus logan and this battle consumes
most of the plot for season one kendall
isn't able to accept that logan is
staying at the company and so he does
what any loyal son would do he starts
planning a vote of no confidence to stab
his dad in the back and to be fair to
kendall logan has completely lost the
plot by this point he's pissing on
office carpets he's hitting children it
all goes a bit pear-shaped after his
stroke not to mention kendall now knows
how underwater the company was under
logan's guidance so he rallies the
troops and starts strategizing how to
gain a majority vote from the board by
this stage frank has been re-hired to
mentor roman in his co role and
therefore has a seat on the board the
core four of kendall roman jerry and
frank reach out to the other board
members and think they have the votes
however disaster strikes during the
meeting as kendall gets stuck in traffic
and therefore has to call into the vote
he is gambling our last dollars at the
track on a horse that's ready for the
glue factory and i'm calling for a vote
of no confidence in him as ceo and
chairman with logan refusing to leave
the room this results in roman turning
traitor and logan retaining his position
he then goes absolutely nuclear on the
boardroom
what's the vote
my son
that was your best shot
you lost i think there's some doubt as
to whether he lost one kendall frank
asha alona off the board fired with
immediate effects
all of the deserters including kendall
are fired this drink is a few key events
for the rest of the show kendall goes on
a revenge tour relapses and starts
plotting how to take down his dad with
stewie and sandy they offer to pay him
out but he instead counters that they
should stage a hostile takeover and name
him ceo at the other end of the spectrum
trader roman now thinks he has a shot at
the top job all he has to do is prove
his worth to logan and is given the task
of overseeing a japanese satellite
launch more of this in a bit during this
whole saga shiv and logan have a huge
falling out she gets a job with gills
starts having an affair with nate and
logan hates the whole thing he even
threatens shiv with outing her affair he
also throws a huge hizzy fit and gets
marsha to tell shiv he's not coming to
the wedding bit of a weak move this is
another example of his mental warfare
logan is unwilling to admit his faults
as both a father and a businessman and
so instead goes on the offensive and
makes others feel guilty or scared this
is his business blueprint eventually he
agrees to come to ship's wedding in this
amazing english castle and this serves
as the setting for kendall's attempted
takeover like i said before stewie and
sandy are relying on kendall's backing
for the takeover he serves logan with a
plan which makes logan go wild again but
then disaster strikes his drug habit
leads to him going on a drive with a
waiter from the wedding they drive off a
bridge and the kid dies kendall tries to
keep this a secret by sneaking back in
but logan pulls the big reveal and says
he knows exactly what happened this
proved to be the bargaining chip logan
needed he agrees to keep kendall safe in
exchange for his undying fealty you're
my boy
you're my number one boy
and just like that kendall drops out of
the hostile takeover and way star royko
remains logan's to command and that's
the end of season one all right guys
right into season two and i'll tell you
who i don't envy screenwriters after
they've just written an amazing first
season every additional season it just
gets harder and harder to have creative
original ideas and that's why i love
limited series like queen's gambit and
mayor of east town and honestly why i
love movies so much give us the good
stuff then wrap it up quickly it's so
much better so how do they spice things
up a bit here well season 2 sees the
introduction of a number of new
characters first of all we get robot
kendall in the aftermath of him killing
that kid and selling his soul to logan
kendall sort of loses all emotion okay
yeah
i mean
my dad wants me to do it i'll do it he
was already quite a rigid character so
him devolving into logan's hand puppet
for most of the series is quite jarring
some people thought this was boring but
i can see the rationale behind the
character arc as it's indicative of
kendall's evolution into his father
logan for the most part is also a robot
he gets angry yeah but he's generally a
high-functioning sociopath with no signs
of empathy or basic human emotions
ladies and gentlemen the first [ __ ]
thing my son's ever done right in his
life kendall's evolution comes full
circle at the end of season two but
we'll get there soon the other new
players this season are the piers family
another old money media dynasty and
their mischievous ceo riya reya
riya raya i don't know they changed her
pronunciation multiple times anyway
let's jump in the first step sees
kendall being pulled out of a rehab
facility to come and help logan save
face he's all over the place and clearly
the rehab didn't really work at this
point stewie and sandy are still intent
on taking over waystar royco but because
they don't have kendall's share of the
company they're reliant on swaying the
other minor shareholders in a proxy
battle uh he's not gonna make it he's
got another pressing matter oh he's got
a more pressing manner
than us taking his empire off his hands
because of this battle logan is advised
by this guy jaime to sell the company he
then holds a weird interview session
with each of the kids to ask their
opinion on the matter at this point we
get the first interesting thread for the
season he offers shiv the role of ceo i
don't think i'm the right person well
you know i'm pretty smart and i think
you are this is obviously a pretty big
deal and calls back to my whole emperor
palpatine bit with kendall now something
of a submissive slave and roman being
broman oh yeah remember that satellite
launch yeah it blew up on the platform
because he asked them to rush it
oh badasses is bad
i'll reiterate it exploded anyway
they're both out of the picture and
conor is useless so logan turns to the
only remaining child he can manipulate
it also doesn't hurt that she's
currently working for gill and this
would force her to quit that job and
like clockwork she quits her job and
logan tells her it'll take three years
to fully integrate into the role
obviously this sets off some alarm bells
for us we know logan's a terrible person
and there's nothing to suggest this
offer is actually real therefore the
logan and kendall relationship from
season 1 is sort of replaced with this
logan and shiv relationship for season
2. i like it it's fun to see him
sparring with a different character and
despite her intelligence it's clear that
logan's business is more important than
their relationship outside of the
serious plot there's a few other fun
things going on in season two first
conor announces he's running for
president yep
this connor and even better his bit is
founded on the idea of removing taxation
these are serious guys
their [ __ ] pieces are [ __ ] yep
they're my pieces of [ __ ]
at the same time he's fully funding a
player that willa wrote which absolutely
sucks just in general there's also a
bunch of fun vacations the family go on
in this season so many nice places
how good's money tom and greg's
relationship gets some more development
as tom gets another promotion and greg
finally reveals that he kept the cruise
documents in order to get a promotion of
his own in many ways greg starts
becoming a weird combination of tom and
logan in this season as he's desperate
to attain more power and status and even
if his blackmail is delivered in a
really friendly way it's actually quite
ruthless wanna bring anything up to you
in a way that feels like horrible but
would it be bad for me to like mention
those to you now are you asking if you
can blackmail me greg and kendall also
form something of a close bond as greg
is a sounding board kendall can talk to
while the rest of the family hate him
while kendall is another ally for greg
during his rise kendall even gets him an
apartment so that's pretty dope roman is
still furious that logan let kendall
back in so easily and so goes out of his
way to disagree with ken on absolutely
everything this is perfect for logan as
he plays the two against each other
which results in them liquidating
lawrence's company i think we got
screwed yeah me too massive [ __ ] up ken
huge
unforgivable roman also enrolls in
waystar's management training program in
a really last-ditch effort to impress
his dad it's kind of cute but tragic at
the same time anyway back to the main
plot logan decides that the best way to
win the proxy battle is by acquiring pgm
the huge media company owned by the
piercers so they meet with elastigirl
and take a trip to meet with nan pierce
in the gang kendall gets a new
girlfriend shits the bed and shiv also
shits the bed at dinner by saying she's
going to be the next ceo
oh for [ __ ] sake dad just tell him
it's gonna be me
logan hates this but nan pierce provides
an ultimatum she'll sell pgm if logan
announces that shift will be his
successor furious at the idea of being
strong arms he storms out and says the
deal is off our suspicions are confirmed
once again logan is never going to give
his power away later the piercers submit
and say they will finalise the deal at a
fancy tech conference however whilst at
the conference they learn that the new
york magazine is planning to release an
expose on the cruise scandal in the next
48 hours this leads to the deal blowing
up as nan pierce becomes the first
person in the entire show to tell logan
no and it's so bloody satisfying go hey
wait we haven't finished we haven't
[ __ ] finished do you hear me oh yeah
reya also gets fired by the piercers and
then somehow becomes the marsha of this
season she starts sleeping with logan
and the kids get a new enemy speaking of
marsha she kind of disappears for most
this season she just becomes a bit whiny
as she's pushed the back of logan's mind
even though i hate her i wasn't super
happy with how this was handled as she's
a really good villain so it was a shame
that she wasn't on the screen anyway
things escalate really quickly heading
into an epic finale a company
whistleblower goes public with the
scandal and our old friend gill forces
the royce to testify before the senate
this leads to some of the funniest
dialogue in the entire show as tom and
greg get grilled the only two-hour
period in which you did not send an
email to mr hirsch with the title
you can't make a tomlet without breaking
some greggs
as this is happening logan knows they
will probably lose the proxy battle
unless they take the company private so
roman is sent to turkey to secure
funding from some multi-billionaire
trust fund baby dude they get the
funding but the shareholders still want
logan to resign obviously he's not going
to do that so instead he demands a blood
sacrifice all the main players join
logan on a yacht and they try to decide
who will take the blame this is the best
episode in the show not only do we get
to go on a nice holiday with the gang
everyone's insecurities are laid there
as it essentially becomes a survival
tribal council everyone has to make a
case for why they should remain safe and
others should be thrown under the bus
this culminates in a private
conversation where logan tells kendall
that he must be the blood sacrifice
kendall accepts this solemnly and in a
touching moment asks logan if he ever
saw him fit to run the company you're
not a killer
you have to be a killer
then
the best moment of the show kendall
fronts the media and for the first time
since season one we see the real him he
tears up his prepared remarks and
instead announces that logan knew about
the cover-up the whole time the truth is
that my father is a malignant presence
a bully and a liar
and he was fully personally aware of
these events for many years
and made efforts to hide and cover up a
cut to logan smiling highlights the
completion of kendall's transformation
he does have the killer instinct after
all and is becoming more like his father
and while this is happening greg stands
at the back of the media conference with
the incriminating cruise documents he
has finally emerged from the shadows and
is ready to choose a side he's decided
to side with kendall in the upcoming
civil war and that's the end of season
two but i think
this is the day
his reign ends
alright welcome to the couch guys and
we're ready to talk about what we think
is gonna happen for season three of
succession and if you're still here you
either love succession as much as i do
or you're deranged or you at least
deserve a medal or something because
it's like half an hour now so thanks if
you're still watching there's two main
reasons you've got my ugly mug and not
like the show
playing at the moment number one the
teaser trailer only goes from a minute
and a half so i don't have that much
footage i'll try and lace it in while we
talk about what we think is gonna happen
number two i'm exhausted i've just done
so much editing so bear with me
hopefully this is okay uh so what are
the main takeaways from the trailer so
the number one thread that i'm most
interested to see what happens obviously
like everyone else is what happens with
the war between logan
and the siblings not just kendall
because it looks like from the trailer
kendall's gonna make a pitch to the
other siblings and convince them that
logan's a terrible person like we know
and that if they side with logan he's
never going to give up the power until
he dies
and before he dies he might run the
company into the ground because he's a
psycho
so it's interesting it looks like shiv
is going to be the main one who's going
to switch sides and potentially she's
then going to clash with kendall so
that'll be interesting to watch on the
other end of the spectrum there's like
tom and greg
they look like they're probably going to
be collateral damage at some point
because they're less protected because
they're not in the family and the other
thing i didn't mention was shiv and tom
was sort of on the rocks in the last
episode of season two so
interesting to see what happens there
other things i'm hoping to see
i suppose
uh i want more marsha i hate the ice
queen but i feel like she's a really
good villain and she wasn't really in
the second season
and now
raya ria reya
now that rey is not in the show anymore
it gives her the space to come back in
other than that i've got no idea from
all the different angles it looks like
the one
confirmation is that logan's [ __ ]
right like either
kendall is able to take him down
if he like he could join stewie and
sandy potentially again even though they
wouldn't trust him or if he
like forms a third party because he's
got a majority vote like the kids
then that just gets really messy but
logan is now in a lot of trouble he's a
wily dude he's evil he's a sociopath
he'll probably get through it again
um what else roman
i don't know what's going on with that
guy oh is conor going to become
president
oh my god that'd be so funny um
not much else to talk about i'm really
looking forward to it hope you guys are
too i'm keen in the next three or four
weeks hopefully it'll be out sometime in
october this is 2021 so if you're
interested in talking succession and
movies and other fun stuff um yeah
please give me a sub i'm i'm more than
happy to talk about this stuff that's
why i'm making this content i like
talking with people about this
would be greatly appreciated and having
said that
i'm gonna go pass out because i'm
exhausted thank you very much guys and
uh i'll talk to you soon all right peace
see you guys
[Music]
broken